every day we get out of bed and we ask
ourselves what should I eat to be able
to digest your food comfortably and
efficiently is the essence of being a
healthy human they were very very clear
a healthy diet consists of
Dr Alan Desmond Allen Desmond Dr Alan
Desmond he's a plant-based
gastroenterologist the author of the new
book The plant-based diet Revolution he
incorporates whole plant-based nutrition
to treat your problems not just the
symptoms I don't accept that concept
that to build meat you gotta eat meat if
we aren't able to go and enjoy our food
it is such a dreadful impact on our
quality of life the statistics on gut
health are terrible one in 15 to 1 in 20
people in the US develop colorectal
cancer in their life one in 10 Americans
have type 2 diabetes that can reduce
your life expectancy by seven years if
you have access to all of these Foods
then choosing plants first is definitely
the way forward
yes choosing plants choosing plants for
weight management for disease prevention
for longevity and even for athletic
performance is indeed and is most
definitely the way forward but what does
that actually mean what does it look
like on a daily basis I think these are
questions all of us grapple with and yet
even the most conscientious Among Us
searching for answers are unfortunately
met with more confusion than Clarity so
today we Rectify that recorded during
our plant power retreat in Italy last
spring the very wise and articulate Dr
Desmond who was just an amazing value
add to that week-long experience throws
down an absolutely compelling master
class on how to understand build and
maintain a healthy gut microbiome and
why this is key to overall well-being we
also bust some nutrition myths and we go
really deep and practical on the
fundamentals of a health the diet what
to eat what to avoid how to do it how to
sustain it and why this is so important
to every facet of your well-being
my mission with this channel is to bring
you cost free the best most impactful
and actionable advice to improve your
daily life and to that end if you have
received value from me it would mean so
much if you could just take a quick
moment to subscribe to this channel to
share it with those who might benefit
from it or resonate with the content and
please feel free to engage in the
comments below as for this video My Hope
Is that it leaves you with the
information the strategies and the
protocols that you need to adopt better
nutrition habits with staying power
because Health isn't a diet it's a
lifestyle
hey everybody my name is Rich I'm
Julie's husband
uh I thought it would be also good for
me to contribute to this Retreat on some
level right
thank you Alan and to kick it off maybe
tell us a little bit about
you know your background and the
evolution of your relationship with
plant-based nutrition and how it kind of
became a central component in how you
think about medicine treating patients
and and just you know well-being in
general
um so I'm a I'm a gastroenterologist a
gut health specialist and my journey
towards recommending a plant-based diet
was driven by my patients so I became I
was a young doctor 2001 2002 graduated
2001 and you go through this process
where you work in different Specialties
so you do Nephrology respiratory
medicine and when I arrived for my first
job on the gastroenterology Ward I saw
people who looked healthy on the outside
but they were really unhealthy on the
inside so there's this whole concept in
Mets and variable concept of medicine
that all Health begins in the gut and
these are individuals who are struggling
with really at the sharp end of
dysfunctional gut health so in hospital
with problems like
ulcer colitis Crohn's disease end-stage
liver disease often driven by
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and
these are patients who get really really
sick so there's some of the sickest
patients in the hospital there's some of
the patients need the most intensive
support
and what Drew me into gastroenterology
is a specialty first of all was
witnessing how much individuals quality
of life improved and how much their
prospects improved if you could restore
their gut health and there was a few
patients in particular who I watched on
that Journey getting better and it was
so transformative I was like I really
want to work in this specialty for the
rest of my career so pretty early on I
was hooked on gastroenterology so that
was like 2003 2004 and of course the
next piece to that is I'm learning all
about the procedures the medications the
diagnoses and I'm explaining these to
patients for the first time and I
realized very early on that every
patient with a digestive health problem
will eventually ask you on the first
conversation or the second conversation
what about food doc what should I eat
what should I avoid and that's a really
powerful question because the patients
made the connection because they've got
a digestive health problem there's a
straight line there for food and they're
asking you well what can I eat to feel
better today what can I eat to feel
better in the future you just told me I
need medication I might need surgery I'm
going to come into your clinic for the
next few years for regular checkups what
can I do with food and I wanted to have
evidence-based answers for that question
there was one case in particular that
always stuck with me and I think it kind
of sowed the seed for me was when I was
like the most Junior doctor on the team
that was taking care of patients there's
this one young man in his early 20s who
was hospitalized with pretty severe
inflammatory bowel disease and so he's
got this Condition it's causing
inflammation in his bowel we're giving
him steroids and other medications to
Tamp the inflammation down she's got
abdominal symptoms and diarrhea he's
losing weight his family are worried
about him and like a lot of young people
he was in he was supposed to be at
University or in his first job or
getting on his life but instead he's in
hospital so we'd been giving him the
steroid medication and the medications
are great don't get me wrong the the
transformative and he'd been getting
steadily better for three days so the
message on the Wardrobe with the
attending with my boss was things are
going the right way you're getting
better the inflammation is reducing
we're going to give you this great
biologic drug we've got some great drugs
from Foundry bowel disease that make a
huge difference to people we're going to
give you this this new drug tomorrow and
we don't think you're going to need
surgery
so he turns to my boss and says you know
I'm feeling hungry again is there
anything I should eat
and his mom who's there to support him
kind of looked in askance to my boss and
my boss said it doesn't matter
eat whatever you like uh when he's got
some calories in here and turned to this
young man's mother and said does he like
McDonald's do you want to bring him in
some McDonald's because we need to uh we
need to build them up a little bit and
he was surprised his mum was surprised I
was pretty surprised as well yeah but
but I mean I'm the I'm the new kid you
know I I well I've been like six years
in medical school but I'm the new kid
um it wasn't my my position but I was a
little bit surprised and that was a
missed opportunity I now know all these
years later right so at that point I
started looking for those evidence-based
answers for my patients and around that
time there was this paper published in a
journal called gosh which is one of our
leading gastroenterology journals it is
what it says okay it's all about the
latest research in Digestive Health it's
called gut it was clickbaity scientists
eat their studies yeah exactly they know
how to suck you in
so there was a paper published in gut
which is the journal you're reading is a
budding gastroenterologist right that's
where all the new science is and there
is this interesting paper and it was UK
data that showed for patients for
inflammatory bowel disease followed over
the course of a year those who ate red
meat were three times more likely to be
hospitalized those who ate processed
meat bacon sausage processed Meats etc
etc were five times more likely to be
hospitalized so even at that point I now
had one answer that I could give to
those patients so I started talking to
my patients about that even as a very
young trainee doctor and that paper the
references and the mechanisms it was
describing led me down some rabbit holes
and then it was a very very gradual
process so it takes another six years
after that story for me to graduate and
become a gastroenterologist 2012 until I
am a gastroenterologist and on a
continuing journey to give my patients
evidence-based answers
I would read all the journals all the
Articles consume all the information and
there's two consistent messages in terms
of keeping your gut healthy and helping
to restore your gut health it's
pneumonia food is really important food
really really does matter
and I had learned to speak to my
patients about
unprocessed food avoid the junk food and
eat more plants and get your protein
from Plants because that supports good
gut health so when I first heard the
phrase Whole Food plant based in about
2015 it was like a a like a a lightning
strike you know it's a whole food
plant-based that's what I've been trying
to explain to my patients it kind of LED
on from there
yeah there's there's an inherent kind of
fascinating irony in the fact that the
the the gut your digestive system
um which is inside our bodies is
actually outward facing right it is
external to our bodies it is the
interface between the outside world and
the interior world through which
nutrients pass and the idea that you
know food wouldn't matter when this is
the basically this is where your body
meets food in the most important way
seems totally insane and yet it is
somewhat of a new idea over the last 10
years we've seen this explosion in not
only the interest around the microbiome
but also a deepening appreciation for
the complexity and importance of the
microbiome with respect to every facet
of health and well-being and I see you
as somebody who's kind of right at the
center of this very important movement
where the science is rapidly evolving
and kind of uh coming out almost weekly
with new understandings because it is so
complex around uh how and why the
microbiome is so important so when you
were talking about the relationship
between food and gut let's take a step
back and explain why gut health is
important to overall health that's such
an awesome question I mean it shouldn't
surprise us but yet it seems surprising
right so I mentioned earlier you know
Hippocrates two and a half thousand
years ago all disease begins in the gut
or if you will all Health begins in the
gut so that's very very ancient wisdom
okay but in recent years we've come to
realize that there was so much wisdom in
that ancient wisdom because we now know
that not only is our gut really
important for regulating our appetites
not only is it responsible for absorbing
nutrients it's also in many ways a
control center for human biology it's
the home of the gut microbiome which we
can talk more about in a few minutes but
that seems to be an incredibly important
part of gut health and good gut health
equals good immune Health there's good
coronary vascular health I mean when I
go to conferences now and I've been
going to conferences for years talking
about gut health in the gut microbiome I
usually now have if it's a general
medical conference I have to sit there
and watch the cardiologist talk about
the gut microbiome watch the
neurologists talk about the gut
microgram watch the endocrinologists
talk about the gut microbiome and it's
got to the point there's so much science
coming out now that we're getting you
have to be like a gut microbiome
sub-specialist you know you can't read
all the research you just can't there's
too much coming out I was very lucky
early on in my career to work for a guy
called Professor Fergus Shanahan so even
when I was you know around in 2004 2005
my supervisor one of my mentors was at
the very Cutting Edge of microbiome
research and I went down to work for him
for a number of years so it's been there
from the start but on a very human level
food
food and gut health really really
matters we eat breakfast lunch dinner we
think about food certainly everyone in
this room thinks about food all the time
and if we aren't able to go and enjoy
our food it is such a dreadful impact on
our quality of life every I mean people
get embarrassed about gut health but
look just take it for me everybody eats
food everybody burps farts poops uses
the toilets these are normal human
functions and to be able to digest your
food comfortably and efficiently is the
essence of being a healthy human so
we've got this concept number one that
all Health begins in the gut and then we
look at the state of gut health right
now
and it it doesn't make sense right so if
to have an efficient comfortable
digestive tract is human an essential
human trait
we look around right like you look at
the United States right now the
statistics on gut health are terrible so
but one in five people in the U.S is
living with daily gastroesophageal
reflux symptoms the number one selling
medication or one of them in the U.S is
a acid suppressing medication to switch
off a normal digestive function to try
and put a lid on digestive symptoms
about 1 in 15 to 1 in 20 people in the
US develop colorectal cancer in their
life diverticular disease is so common
that people don't even refer to it as a
disease anymore they refer to it as
diverticulosis it's normal but it's not
normal it's not inevitable there are
places in the world where people don't
get diverticular disease it wasn't
always an inevitable part to The Human
Condition yet it hospitalizes people
costs the US economy nine billion
dollars a year now and when again when
you go and you look at the evidence for
well look does food matter is the way I
eat is going to help protect my gut
health and keep me out of hospital so I
substantially reduce my risk of
colorectal cancer substantially reduce
my risk of all of these problems Food
Matters patients are right food really
matters and how do we eat to support
prevent preserve our gut health it
really is I mean a whole food
plant-based diet doesn't have to be
exclusively plant-based how we can get
into that but if you are eating the same
healthy diet that we recommend for heart
health and brain health and lung Health
a healthy Whole Food plant-based diet
you're getting I mean half your food
from fruits and vegetables but a third
your food from healthy whole grains
you're getting your protein from healthy
plant-based sources maybe a little bit
of fermented food a little bit of
healthy plant-derived oils and if you
can establish that healthy dietary
pattern and there is room for small
amounts of animal products in there as
an option but far less than people think
then you are eating in a way that is
really going to support protect and
preserve your gut health for sure yeah I
think I think what's the key Point here
is for me at least is is agency because
we can go down this microbiome rabbit
hole and it's super fascinating these
studies and what they're telling us of
about the you know the intricacies of
what's Happening inside of our bodies
but what I kind of extract from all of
this and and kind of Leverage in a
practical way is the mutability of the
gut microbiome so I had I had Tim
Spector on the podcast recently but it
was really compelling to hear him talk
about his developing understanding of
the importance of the microbiome in the
context of studying Twins and trying to
understand why identical twins would
have different Health outcomes
throughout their life thinking that this
is uh emanating from from genetics right
it's a it was a kind of nurture nature
study as you know I'm sure you know all
about this but what was discovered was
the differ the differential in those
outcomes really could be rooted to the
differential in their gut microbiome so
uh we're all very different people we
look different but but ultimately the
DNA that we that that we have
um is almost identical to each other and
yet our microbiomes if we were to sample
all of that would be wildly different in
this room uh but it's very responsive
right when you talk about food
um the the reparative uh kind of
mechanism around the microbiome you know
is such that if you start to treat it
right you can reverse prevent like sort
of set yourself on a different
trajectory you can't change your genes
but you can change the nature of your
gut microbiome to kind of course correct
wherever you're at and get on a better
track which I love and when you were
talking about all these diseases uh you
know diverticulitis or you know it's
like you think about what's causing this
from you know overuse of antibiotics to
environmental toxins and you know Zach
Bush would say glyphosate or you know
the types of foods that we're eating the
ultra processed foods and and everything
that's going on we're like assailing our
microbiome continually and to the extent
that we can like be more mindful about
what that looks like and make better
choices we can actually change the
trajectory of our health back to that
notion of agency which I think is really
cool yeah it's it's incredible and you
know I love Tim's research and I you
know
consume it voraciously and then as a
clinician I've got to take all of that
high level research and try to bring it
to my practice on a daily basis and it's
interesting because the things that help
to build a healthy gut microbiome also
build a healthy human so I mean when you
hear uh microbiome researchers speaking
they've talked about eating a varied
plant-based diet getting enough sleep
spending time in nature avoiding
unnecessary medications I mean
antibiotics are great they're
life-saving but not taking them if
they're unnecessary we also know from
researcher Tim is involved the American
gut project at eating animal products
brings antibiotic looks into your
digestive system and into your gut
microbiome and those are practices that
preserve a healthy human as well as a
healthy gut microbiome and again that
shouldn't surprise us right
um and I know you've gone deep on the
microbiome but I mean it's something
that's been on my mind this is the early
part of my career but should be on all
of our minds I mean so the gut
microbiome you've got your maybe the
numbers vary depending on the latest
count but maybe 60 trillion bacteria
yeasts viruses and archaea living
predominantly within your large bowel
your colon they these bugs have been on
this Earth for like two to three billion
years they're far more ancient than
humans we've been around for maybe 200
000 years so if you think about where
the microbiome came from Rich I mean it
it gets a little bit meta doesn't it
because you think about this the first
two primitive cells on this planet that
gave rice rise to every human and every
other animal on the planet
when those two little cells got together
they were surrounded by viruses yeasts
and you know the archaea and the
bacteria they were part of the gut
microbiome part of the microbiome or the
The Meta The Meta microbiome the
microbiome right the macro the metal
I've lost it the metamacro The Meta Meta
macro microbiome and you know so that's
incredible that that's incredible and we
are still carrying those bugs with us in
our digestive tract every day and we
only really found out about it uh maybe
600 years ago with the Advent of
microscopes you know what did the
scientists do they started looking at
poo under the microscope you know 600
years ago and they saw these tiny living
creatures that were coming from the
digestive tract they call them animal
kills right like molecules little tiny
little animals and it's only yeah right
I wish they'd stuck with that name
instead of bacteria yeast and viruses
but animal kills what a lovely old name
for these little bugs in our gut and
then in the last 10 and 20 years and you
know my former mentor like Fergus
Shannon and obviously Tim Spector people
like Ted Dinan uh people like Professor
Tom Cotter who I'm very lucky to be
working on a project with now
um have led the charge on that research
and thanks to the you know the Advent of
the new genetic analyzes and the costs
have come down and throughput has come
down that we've learned so much about
the microbiome in the last several years
and just like one little statistic that
kind of crystallizes it for me which is
only like research published in the
Netherlands just a few weeks ago so
these researchers looking at the impact
of the gut microbiome and health so they
measured plasma metabolites okay so if
you go to the doctor and you get a blood
test so we're measuring different
molecules in your bloodstream so various
you know cholesterols and lipids
inflammatory protein CRP you're familiar
with hearing about those there's lots of
other metabolites that you don't really
hear about at the lab when you go to see
your GP so these researchers measured
everything they could measure in the
plasma in their lab and determined that
of the 1200 metabolites that they could
measure in the lab
two-thirds were directly dependent on
the individual's diet and microbiome so
two-thirds of the 1200 metabolites
flowing through your bloodstream are
determined by your diet and you've got
microbiome Health compared to less than
five percent determined by our genetics
wow so it's no surprise
that our gut microbiome and the food
that we eat have such a measurable
impact on our Health and Longevity great
well let's let's dive into that a little
bit then
um let's say somebody just heard what
you said and they are thinking wow I've
never thought of that in that way before
so first of all how do I find out the
State of the Union of my you know gut
microbiome I've never thought about it
before so I would like to have it tested
and if I go have it tested how do I do
that and what should I be looking for
and then sort of secondary to that we
can get into kind of
just best practices and protocols to
improve or maintain a healthy gut
microbiome yeah well I would say the
first the second bit comes first okay so
it'd be I think before you you start to
inquire into your current gut microbiome
Health you probably want to get those
best practices dialed in first okay
because that's you want to know the
things are on point now these things we
sometimes refer to as the basics but of
course they're not basic anymore they're
really unusual it's really difficult in
the current food culture and in our
current Lifestyles to actually live in a
way that supports our overall health let
alone our gut microbial Health even
though often it's the same thing I mean
when you I mean one of the key things is
the diversity of plants in your diet and
you know Tim was involved in the
research that brought that Concept in to
the public sphere so the 30 plants a
week so we week right so that came from
the American gut project so 11
000 citizen scientists uh sent their
poop to the lab okay citizen scientists
contributing to understanding the gut
microbiome and one of the key findings
from that paper was that the diversity
and health if you've got microbiome
crucially depends number one determinant
depends on the diversity of plants in
your diet and individuals who consume
more than 30 plants per week unlock
certain gut microbial benefits that
other people don't get I'm sure if
people have just listened to the
podcasts with Tim and they're listening
to this now there's repeat there okay
but even in that paper fewer than one in
250 people were hitting that Mark so
that's really really rare and if you
look at the evidence on how much a
healthy diet and lifestyle impacts Your
Health and Longevity which is
substantial I mean a healthy plant power
diet can add 10 to 14 years of life
expectancy
which is incredible 10 years of healthy
life expectancy which is incredible I
mean who doesn't want 10 extra years of
healthy life I mean that's the
difference between seeing your
grandchildren finish grade school and
being there when they graduate
University or have their first art
exhibition or write their first book
that's I mean that's that's powerful
medicine right but when you look at all
of those studies what you see is the
people who are getting the greatest
benefits from their diet and lifestyle
in those studies are in a tiny minority
because our current diet and Lifestyles
just don't support Health and Longevity
anymore so in order to you asked a
really good question we're going to read
along answer I apologize but before you
embark on discovering
the secrets of your personal gut
microbiome I would suggest that you
spend some time before you get any of
those tests done
um just working on your daily routine
and making sure that you are eating and
living to support a healthy gut
microbiome so what are the things yeah
yeah yeah yeah I love that
um we we uh this notion of of diversity
being Paramount is so interesting to me
for for many reasons but as you're as
you were sharing about that I'm thinking
about
I mean we're in Italy uh Julie and I in
our family we were in Florence for a
couple days before uh The Retreat
started and we were going to Galleries
and museums and so we have you know the
David and Michelangelo and da Vinci on
our mind and I'm thinking about the
Vitruvian Man and the the proportions
that sort of scale up in different ways
in nature and when you talk about the
importance of diversity in your diet as
a marker for gut health this is a a
truth or a notion that also appears
throughout nature from the micro all the
way to the macro ecosystems are
healthier with diversity human
populations are more robust and and
healthier when we have a diversity of
perspectives Etc like this is like it's
sort of like uh the Fibonacci sequence
right like this is like a truth
um that is core and important for every
component of like how we navigate the
world to what we eat right so I love
that idea and the Simplicity of just 30
plants a week kind of roots it in your
Consciousness so you can kind of very
easily reflect upon that every time
you're making a food choice
absolutely and that's maybe the first
point or the first practice building a
planned diverse diet of course a healthy
Whole Food plant-based diet ticks that
box and then some okay so if you're
eating like a healthy Whole Food
plant-based diet as you and I both
espouse and promote and live you're
going to be eating 60 or 70 or 80
different plants per week you know we
probably had 30 to 40 plants yesterday
here together eating gorgeous diverse
plant-based food which did which was
delicious and beautifully prepared But
ultimately was pretty simple it was like
pasta and tomatoes and garlic and onion
and seasoning and some leaves and some
other leaves and some more leaves and
that really helps to build it and it's
no surprise that vegans or people who
eat plant-based hit that marker
consistently they hit the plant-based
diversity marker consistently how do we
know that well we look at the dietary
and intakes of plant-based eaters versus
carnivores or omnivores I should say and
we've known since the 1970s that about
the average fiber intake for an omnivore
in high income country is about 20 grams
of fiber per day maybe a little bit
lower than that but we've known since
the 1970s that even in the UK there was
Data looking dietary fiber intake in
vegans and even then they were hitting
like 44 grams which is a much more
representative number of what we should
eat for a healthy gut we've seen that
validated even recently a huge study
across the U.S Europe and Asia again
vegans vegetarians particularly vegans
get way more dietary fiber than people
who are not vegan that's one of the key
reasons why people who eat plant-based
are less likely to develop diverticular
disease colorectal cancer why a healthy
diet helps to prevent conditions like
inflammatory bowel disease Crohn's
disease and that comes back to the
diversity pieces well there's definitely
an overlap there but of course I'm not
blaming people who have these conditions
my God as I said it's really really
difficult to hit those numbers in the
current food culture so that's the plant
diversity aspect the second aspect is
Ditch the junk I mean the junk food
which now or junk food also known as
junk
which makes up like 60 to the calories
that we consume in high income countries
um so the processed chips and dips the
you know the pep well I won't mention a
brand but those little salami sticks
that you can buy at the drugstore all of
that stuff okay Slim Jims
about the brand are you afraid of big
slim jim yeah yeah I don't uh I don't
want slim jim adding me you know coming
at me you know I'll have to leave
Twitter
[Laughter]
Foods they're junk make up 60 to the
calories consumed in high income
countries right now they have no
business in the human digestive tract uh
the modern food industry has been
pumping chemicals like maltodextrin
polysorbet AC carboxymethyl cellulose
carrageenan lecithins these artificially
produced flavor enhancers and
emulsifiers into the food System since
the 1950s and 60s they take stuff that
isn't food and makes it taste like food
makes it soft and moist and flavoursome
makes it shelf stable easy to ship
cheaper to produce and we we love it I
mean it's it's very carefully designed
to appeal to our primitive monkey brain
that likes sweet things and salty things
and fatty things and we love eating it
but no business in the human digestive
tract and then when you look at
individual components of those junk
foods and the mechanisms what they do to
our digestive tract I'll give you an
example okay so there's a there's an
artificial sugar called maltodextrin
it's been described in the U.S as a
ubiquitous food additive
I've had a lot of that in my lifetime
because as an endurance athlete
maltodextrin is sort of a lower glycemic
carbohydrate that you can mix with water
and kind of sip on throughout a very
long you know sort of session so I've
probably had more than a fair share of
human dosage of that over the course of
my lifetime oh dear so you're making me
worry yeah yeah
well let's talk about maltodextrin then
let's talk about Rich's gut microbiome
so so what we know is you're not alone
in that because the average U.S citizen
consumes maltodextrin three times a day
because it's in almost every processed
food you flip over almost any processed
food and you'll see maltodextrin the
slow release stable artificial
carbohydrate that's made in a food in a
chemical Factory this powder that's
added to our food so what does it do
well one of the things that it does in
our gut microbiome is it promotes the
growth of a bacterium called adherent in
invasive E coli ah adherent invasive E
coli aihc so this bug now becomes
product prevalent within our gut
microbiome when we consume a lot of
maltodextrin for some reason that bug
enjoys eating the byproducts of malted
extra so why does that matter well
adherent invasive E coli is just one of
the components that helps to trigger the
abnormal immune response that one sees
in Crohn's disease so Crohn's disease
can be a very devastating GI condition
predominantly emerges in people in their
20s and 30s the young man I mentioned
earlier in the story was on the ward
with crohn's disease hospitalized about
only 25 percent of people with crohn's
disease say that they have good overall
quality of life it's very it's very very
impactful on people so it's a
multifactorial illness and genetics play
a part and there are other components
obviously but the adherent invasive E
coli has a role to play in that disease
and then you add to that rich in order
for that bug to cause Mayhem in your
digestive tract it needs to get really
close to the cells that line your gut of
course the cells that line your gut have
this lovely protective layer of goo
called mucin that prevents abnormal
interactions with pathobiomes harmful
bacterium harmful bacteria but guess
what the junk Foods also contain
emulsifiers like polysorbate and
carrageenan and lecithins that degrade
raid the mucin layer okay and also we
know that in a fiber deficient diet your
gut microbiome isn't receiving the
microbiome available carbohydrates that
it thrives on so it turns to the mucin
layer for food and starts to degrade it
so you that allows this adherent in base
of E coli to come in contact with the
micropore cells in the lining of your
terminal ileum and that is a key part of
the development of conditions like
inflammatory bowel disease well that's
fascinating
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
you mentioned uh you sort of with a slip
at the tongue you said carnivore a
minute ago
um
and uh you also mentioned uh sort of a
low fiber diet so I want to get into
that a little bit I think irrespective
of whatever your your diet proclivity is
everyone would basically unanimously
agree that Ultra processed foods the
ufps the junk has no place in in on a
healthy plate right and once we depart
from there though the opinions start to
flare in all sorts of different
directions and I'm imagining the
well-intentioned person who opens up
their social media on their phone or
their Instagram and and they see a clip
of Alan saying exactly what he just said
and they scroll and then they see Dr B
and he's talking about 30 plants a week
Etc but then keep scrolling and there's
uh Dave asprey saying how kale is is
toxic and Dr gundry who's talking about
lectins and why we shouldn't eat beans
and then there's the carnivore
enthusiasts and the liver King who are
telling you do you need to eat organ
meats and everything you've heard about
fiber is incorrect and we need to
rethink cholesterol and Etc my point
being that for somebody who is in in the
process of a good faith like desire to
kind of understand like hey what should
I do like on a very I just want just
tell me like what's healthy what's not I
go online everybody's saying something
different these people are all crazy and
it reminds me of you know that kind of
famous
well-known you know tobacco industry
campaign where the advertising agencies
understood and learned that like doubt
was their product right and so I think
all the con the sort of conflicting
messaging out there
uh sort of roots people in a certain
paralysis where it's like well I'll just
keep doing what I'm doing because these
people you know they can't they can't
get their together and agree on
anything so
um I'll just wait until there seems to
be a little bit more clarity well
will come to the carnivores in a minute
because there's there's a lot to be said
about that
so every day we get out of bed and we
ask ourselves what should I eat and my
patients ask me what should I eat and
some people go on social media to figure
out what should I eat so that's a really
really important question and food is in
many ways the number one determined ever
Health and Longevity and it's really
really important food is powerful
medicine and that's true for gut health
but overall health as well we touched on
that already so in 2019 one of the most
prominent and long-standing medical
journals in the world the Lancet medical
journal very respected journals been
around for centuries set up a commission
and published the report to that
commission and the Lancet because
there's such a well-respected and
high-powered Journal every now and then
they will set up a commission to look at
a very very important question in
medicine health and nutrition and the
question that they were trying to answer
with this commission was what should I
eat not just you not just me but the 8
billion humans on Earth what should we
eat to be the healthiest possible
version of ourselves and that goes for
the 3 3.5 billion people on Earth who
are living with diseases of excess
because they're eating too many calories
and too many other calories are coming
from unhelpful sources it also goes for
the 800 million people on Earth who are
living with the health impacts of not
having access to food and not having
access to sufficient calories and
sufficient healthy calories in their
day-to-day life so for air and everybody
in between what should we eat they chose
you know well-respected hand-picked
academics from August academic
institutions like Harvard and UCL
Imperial around the world and ask them
to go and look at Decades of scientific
evidence and come back with a blueprint
for a healthy diet
so they published that in 2019 the
report of the eat Lancer commission and
they were very very clear that a healthy
diet consists of getting about half your
food in the form of fruits and
vegetables about one third of your food
from whole grains and the whole
diversity of whole grains that exist by
making sure the rest of your food is
predominantly made up with higher
protein in all plants contain protein
but higher protein plants your legumes
your beans your chickpeas your lentils
your black beans and all that good stuff
that you need to have some healthy
plant-derived oils so extra virgin olive
oil Etc can be added in small quantities
to that healthy dietary pattern and then
when it comes to the animal products as
I said earlier there is a place and this
is true in gut health practice but also
on this big question there is a place if
you have that healthy dietary pattern
established for small amounts of animal
products in there so water water what
kind of amounts are we talking about
well bacon and processed meat zero bacon
processed meat ham salami sausage are
probably responsible for 640 000 deaths
every year on Earth predominantly driven
by coronavastages cancer and
complications of type 2 diabetes no
dietary recommendations include bacon
it's just not on the plate at all so
then when it comes to red meat so your
you know pasture-raised
Buffalo cow lamb Etc they said yep you
can have it but we would recommend based
on the evidence that you would limit
your consumption to about 7 to 14 grams
per day that's less than half an ounce
quarter of an ounce to half an ounce so
that would add up to maybe one small
serving of red meat per week okay and
but in the body of the report they said
look the safest amount of red meat to
consume is probably zero but it's
difficult to demonstrate harm at low
levels of consumption so we've allowed
this within the within the within the
healthy place when it came to eggs they
reckoned about a half an egg per day
when it came to Fish and Chicken one to
two ounces per day but it was clear
reading the report that if you are lucky
enough and privileged enough to live in
a situation where you have access to all
of these foods and not everybody does
that's for sure but if you have access
to all of these Foods then choosing
plants first is definitely the way
forward now that International Panel of
experts rep reported that if they could
like flick a switch and get everybody on
Earth the resources and the ability and
the government policies and the food
structures to support that it would
prevent 11 to 12 million human deaths
every single year
again due to preventing so many cases of
various cancers colorectal cancer which
I deal with all the time at work type 2
diabetes heart disease etc etc etc but
also it would prevent hundreds of
millions of trips to the emergency room
Corner catheterizations coronary artery
bypass graphs prescriptions for statins
courses of chemotherapy you know colonic
polypectomies which is something I do so
there's that now for years as an
advocate of a healthy Whole Food
plant-based diet when that report came
out I was astounded because it was
another one of those moments where
throughout that report they used the
term Whole Food plant-based it's all
over the report and they give resources
for governments and health organizations
to support their individual economy to
support that way of eating so that was a
real another lightning moment for me so
I was like well this makes sense to me
because this is how I've been asking my
patients to eat this also supports
really good gut health so when that
report came out
the meat component was actually very
very low right like 7 to 14 grams but
for years people have been saying to me
as an advocate for a healthy Whole Food
plant-based diet
you know water because you mentioned
carnivore
for years we would be asked well what
about uh paleo that was the thing paleo
and obviously the paleo diet doesn't
match up but what I just described it
doesn't match up at a healthy Whole Food
plant-based diet but
it there's an overlap okay so I would
look at the Paleo Advocates I think
actually we agree on a lot of stuff and
you agree and I agree on a lot of stuff
which also agrees with the public health
and epidemiology and mechanistic stuff
okay so we both agree junk food is bad
added sugar is bad added salt is bad
junk food is out no Dairy you mean milk
is for babies that's I mean that seems
very clear to me you know milk is for
babies humans as adults don't need to
consume milk and we agree that people
should have some fruits and leafy greens
and a variety of plants even it was
mentioned by the Paleo proponents so
we're the only place we really differed
was where should we get our protein so
from the plant-based perspective we
would say you need to get your protein
from uh plants because the data shows
that the more of the protein that we get
from Plants the healthier we are and
that goes for bowel cancer diverticities
in all of those conditions whereas the
Paleo folk would say oh no you should
get your of protein from Mis and you
know because humans are made out of meat
so we should eat meat so I think
basically but is is there's a corollary
to that which is that that plant protein
is inferior in terms of its
bioavailability and in terms of its
ratio of essential amino acids so I
think it would be helpful to kind of
speak to that question it is the
low-hanging fruit where do you get your
protein kind of recurring you know
looping question but yet you know that
question persists there are a lot of
people I think that are you know either
predominantly plant-based or or
plant-based curious but are still kind
of reticent because they're concerned
about uh not just how much protein
they're getting but is this the type the
quality of protein that I need to
maintain my muscle mass and I think you
know in In fairness there is a lot of
emerging science right now coming out
that as we age age that we should
increase our protein intake and and that
it's very important to maintain muscle
mass to prevent you know like you know
basically like if you fall breaking your
hip as you're an older person Etc uh so
as you get older you start thinking
about that more and I and I can see how
that would push a certain individual
either towards meat or back to meat
because of that concern or consideration
so do you have thoughts on that it's
where do you get your protein I always
welcome that question because it's so
such an important question but of course
being protein aware it doesn't mean
being meat aware that those aren't the
same thing so we've known for a long
time that even people who eat very
strictly vegan or vegetarian
um without e without you know trying
without taking protein shakes or
whatever just ordinary folks going about
their day-to-day business are getting
about 70 to 80 grams of protein per day
average some more some less probably the
top five percent getting about 100 grams
of protein per day and that comes from
Canadian data from the uh Seven Day
Adventists in Canada there's similar
data out of Germany confirming that and
lots of studies showing that you know
vegans and vegetarians eat lots of
protein without having to think about it
too much so there's that so they're
getting protein
and then there's this idea that the
protein that we get from meat is higher
quality of protein I mean the
epidemiological evidence and the health
outcome evidence tells the opposite
story and I'm very confident in saying
that the protein we get from plants is
high quality protein it is the high
quality protein because the research
shows us that well first of all among uh
young men vegan young men don't have
lower body muscle than non-vegan young
men we've seen emerging data in recent
years showing that if you put athletes
into the gym and you put them on a high
protein diet whether that high protein
diet is vegan or meat based they get the
same muscular gains and performance
gains going to the gym you talked about
muscle loss as we age now of course
muscle loss when we age is more about
weight-bearing exercise than it is about
diet but diet is important and we saw a
study published last year showing that
in older folks the higher proportion of
their protein calories that they get
from Plants the lower their risk of
age-related sarcopenia the concept that
we don't get all the amino acids that we
need to get from our plant-based diet is
also a fallacy I mean gram for a gram
you know if you eat a piece of meat if I
eat a piece of my arm right now I'm
going to get the perfect balance of
amino acids for a human obviously but
you get that from a plant-based diet too
I mean even 20 years ago when the
American Medical Association published
their dietary guidelines for reducing
cardiovascular disease they mentioned
the concept of the whole protein concept
so that you need to eat meat and if you
don't eat meat you should have quinoa or
soy because those have the full
complement of amino acids incomplete
incomplete sources of protein but I
think it was
um I can't quite remember which doctor
it was but a doctor wrote to them and
said that's not true and they wrote back
and said and the data that the response
letter was published it was Dr John
McDougall wrote to them and called them
out and said that's not true because all
plants contain all of the amino acids
that humans need to be healthy including
the essential amino acids in different
proportion and if you're eating a varied
diet that includes fruits and vegetables
and three servings of whole grains and
legumes you will get all of those amino
acids so if you're going to use the
whole protein analogy a whole food
plant-based diet is a whole source of
protein and then there's the outcome
data so replacing animal protein with
plant protein once you've established
that healthy dietary pattern
that's a really smart move even
replacing small amounts of animal
protein with small amounts of plant
protein has very significant benefits on
reducing your carnivascular disease
stroke type 2 diabetes etc etc so I
don't accept that concept that to build
meat you gotta eat meat and E and the
longevity piece and the long-term Health
piece is really interesting but the
carnivore crowds or Advocates have taken
it to another extreme right they've gone
further than paleo and they're now
saying that we should only ease Mis so
from a GI perspective as a
gastroenterologist first of all I'm just
a little bit suspicious because yeah a
little bit suspicious so the human GI
tract produces enzymes to digest food
there's three broad types there are the
lipases which break down oils and fats
there's the proteolytic enzymes which
break down protein you've got like
trypsin chemotrypsin and pepsin and then
you've got this group of enzymes called
amylases we were talking we were talking
about this earlier before I came into
the room amylases so amylases break down
starch
plants carbohydrates so as soon as food
goes into your mouth it's exposed to
amylases which are there to break down
the starch and the carbohydrates yet the
people who are promoting this meat
exclusive way of dieting of eating or
saying well actually the perfect diet
for a human is like don't eat any starch
it's so bad for you but it seems like
our bodies are intrinsically designed to
digest it and sure they will talk about
the you know the mechanistic data you
alluded to some of it earlier you know
the nutrient profile the bioavailability
this is all kind of lab based
theoretical stuff and it's interesting
and some of it is patently false to be
honest I mean the nutrients that we get
from our plants are also absorbed you
know and also get into our bloodstream
and people who eat a healthy plant-based
diet get more fiber more folate more
vitamin A vitamin C vitamin E more
magnesium or more potassium in their
diet than omnivores do and all of these
things have tremendous health benefits
but when it comes to the meat specific
part to the story
if you want to know what a healthy diet
looks like
you need to go out look at real world
evidence you've got to go and pursue
scientifically what does a healthy diet
look like you'd and this is a whole part
of medicine this is a whole science
which we refer to as epidemiology has a
big overlap with public health it's been
around for a long time and what it tells
us is that you've got to go in the real
world and find out what's happening so
just a little bit of background to
Public Health and epidemiology so
crucial to medicine it's the starting
point for public health advice and if we
go back to like 1855 there was this have
you heard the Broad Street pump have you
ever heard that story I don't think so
no so we're leaving gut health
temporarily but we'll come back okay so
In 1855 there's a cholera outbreak in
London and you know you know thousands
of people are dying okay
and that at the time most of the medical
experts
including a medical celebrity and
influencer called Florence Nightingale
who is a real person at United Okay so
there is a real person they thought that
the cholera outbreak was being caused by
miasma so unhealthy air the stench from
the Thames basically that's what they
thought was causing a cholera but there
was this young doctor called Dr John
snow and he had a different Theory so
his theory was that it was being caused
by bad water there was a water-borne
disease so he had a controversial
opinion just like the the carnivores I
guess okay so he went out into the real
world he didn't disappear into the lab
to figure out in his head how water
could be causing this problem he went
into the real world and he mapped out
cases of Cholera in London and he found
out that they were clustered around a
water pump on Broad Street because
people didn't have have running water
then they had to go to the pump which
was essentially a well and pump water
that's how you got your water so he
found these cases clustering around the
Broad Street pump he petitioned the
council to shut off the pump they said
no you're crazy it's caused by miasma
check with Florence Nightingale you know
she'll if you uh follow her on Instagram
she she let you know she let you know
what's going on she's got hot takes yeah
hot takes all day long right but so they
said no you know your your theory
doesn't stand up we already know what's
caused but so he took bold action I like
to think he went out in the middle of
the night but what he did is he went he
took the handle off the pump
at the end of the cholera
um the cholera outbreak in London saved
lives and that was the beginning of
Public Health epidemiology medicine so
you go into the real world you don't
just sit in your room theorizing you
find out what's happening in the real
world you intervene and see if it makes
a difference so 25 years ago we had
there's this awful condition you may be
familiar with I'm sure sudden infant
death syndrome very tragic condition
um not something I'm a specialist in but
I'm aware of the story okay so young
babies found dead very awful right just
awful so there was a big move to try and
figure out why this was happening and 25
years ago a whole bunch of scientists
did some incredible epidemiological work
they went into the real world
and it recorded everything about babies
everything they did how they were born
how they ate how they slept how their
parents Asians slept their daily routine
and they discovered by observing what
was happening in the real world was that
babies who would lay on their front were
more likely to suffer this terrible
illness and that gave us the back to
sleep campaign 25 years ago and they
encouraged parents to put their babies
to sleep on their back and they didn't
even know why but good epidemiology
saved thousands of lives because the
countries had implemented that advice
sudden Foundation went down by like 78
so when we look currently when you look
at the epidemiological science on
nutrition and health heart disease type
2 diabetes colon cancer cluster around
meat consumption in just the same way
that cholera clustered around the Broad
Street pump but and we have Decades of
epidemiological evidence that support
that and not only that we've got the
mechanistic data that shows us why Mis
is bad for you in certainly in excess we
know about the heterocyclic amines and
the polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons and
what the heme iron does increasing risk
of colon cancer about the nitrates and
nitrites that are added to processed
meat which then combine with the bacon
when you cook it to form these
carcinogenic nitrous amines we know what
an what the standard Western diet does
that have got microbiome and how that
promotes a gut microbiome environment
that is conducive to disease so we've
got the real world data as a starting
point we've got the mechanistic data
that explains what we're seeing in the
real world and then we've got the
intervention studies that show that you
can turn it around but the carnivore
Advocates just put their thumb over all
of that
and say that's nonsense I don't believe
it why because it doesn't agree with
their concept of what a healthy diet
looks like beautifully put thank you for
that that was a bit of a mic drop moment
um
[Music]
foreign I think this is uh an
appropriate time to open it up to all of
your questions so yeah so let's let's
let's open it up let's uh let's get your
questions on the mic if we could though
first of all thank you it's amazing to
see doctors more and more doctors uh
defending this and I'm it's really
grateful for it
um so
a little bit of a personal story but I
think it could be General so I think
during the pandemic Ann and I we're
mostly doing plant-based diet
but then at the end of it or off wait to
it I I got some uh health issues kind of
a burnout and I ended up having very low
um gut bacteria diversity so gut
problems
um so I truly believe on the diet but I
guess there's other factors that can
impact
um
the the gut probably the amount of
alcohol that I started drinking during
the pandemic while cooking
um so I developed cooking skills but I
guess sleep and other things what what
would be other than
um the diet other very important factors
second question I would have is uh I
kind of discussed this with you but I
think it would be important to to
discuss broadly uh what is being done in
the medical community to even spread
this word uh more thank you thanks Paula
that's a great question and you I mean
we've just been through this incredibly
stressful three-year period for
everybody
and the impact that stress has on our
digestive health it cannot be
understated
it I talk to my patients with my
patients about this all the time okay so
you imagine someone who's got perfect
gut health like rock solid and they walk
out the front door and they see the
horrible car accident or they get some
terrible news they find out you know
something Dreadful has happened to a
family member and people will react to
that with nausea they may vomit they may
lose their appetite they will go for
they'll meet their buddy for lunch the
next day and their buddy will say oh
you're not eating and they say well I
had this terrible thing happened to me
yesterday and their friend gets it
and say okay tell me about it that's
your gut brain access in action that is
your digestive health that is your
appetite that is the peristaltic waves
that run through your gut and do the do
the house cleaning for your gut
microbiome changing due to a 100
emotional trigger nothing else
so if you imagine that you're living
with 10 of that stress or 10 15 or 20 of
that stress on a daily basis and you may
not even recognize it it changes the gut
microbial environment it changes your
stool frequency it changes your appetite
it changes the foods that you consume
which is the number one determinant
you've got microbiome so of course it
matters so we talked about you know food
and fermented foods and diversity and
all that kind of stuff and that's those
are the basics but Stress Management is
really really important if we don't you
know sort out the stress we're not going
to fix your tummy and the data supports
that
um so there is a condition which a lot
of gastroenterologists refer to as
irritable bowel syndrome I don't use
that phraseology in my clinic I call
that a functional GI disorder and we try
to get into what's driving it I don't
think the term IBS is helpful it's way
more than irritable okay having poor
Digestive Health I mean we've seen data
showing that people with severe IBS
would give live 10 years of life
expectancy to restore their gut health
so it's Way Beyond irritable and I've
seen so many people and patients who've
been housebound and lost their jobs
because of
IBS but it is the term that's used in
the literature okay so unexplained
abdominal symptoms and we've seen data
showing that mindful meditation got
specific hypnotherapy are as effective
if not more effective than medication
and a huge adjunct to healthy dietary
change in restoring your gut health so
for years I've been recommending that my
patients engage in gut specific
hypnotherapy or mindfulness meditation
and the data tells us that if we take
patients with severe unexplained
abdominal symptoms or functional GI
symptoms that about 70 percent of them
will see marked improvement with Stress
Management particularly mindfulness
meditation they're calming the gut brain
axis and the great thing about that
prescription
is the side effect of profile which is
better quality of life greater
understanding of others etc etc so the
stress component is huge and a very
short answer alcohol is bad for good
[Applause]
great
oh it's changing I mean we were talking
I was talking about this outside I mean
in
2014 I think uh Dr Kim Williams the most
senior
um cardiologist in America at the time
president American Medical Association
um who's in charge of setting the
guidelines to help prevent and treat the
number one killer cardiovascular disease
made that statement there are two kinds
of cardiologists uh vegans and those who
haven't read the data
okay and he said that he said that as a
you know to stir the pot a little bit
but within a short number of years the
American Health the American Hearts
Association had published their dietary
guidelines for a carnivascular disease
prevention which is incredibly important
and also connected to God health of
course at the godheart connection is
real we could have a tmao and they've
got microbiome and all that I'm sure
you've heard that story before but a few
years later they published their
guidelines for preventing the number one
killer and they said diet is really
really important and we know the people
sand based diet may be 50 to 60 less
likely to ever develop coronary artery
disease so they recognized that and
recommended a Mediterranean style
vegetarian diet a vegetarian dietary
pattern to prevent heart disease you
know in 2019 the
um the American the panel in the US
charge for writing the guidelines for
treating type 2 diabetes Nails their
colors to the mass I mean that one in 10
Americans have type 2 diabetes that can
reduce your life expectancy by seven
years landoon Hospital put on permanent
medication you can end up in dialysis
with this condition so there are
guidelines now saying have done since
every patient should be supported in
attaining and maintaining a healthy body
weight through a predominantly
plant-based diet you know the research
on this has come there's a paper
published out of the UK just last year
excuse me last week
um looking at how much healthier people
are if they limit their meat consumption
and eat more fruits vegetables whole
grains and legumes and the the title of
the paper is adherence to a plant-based
diet and Longevity and major
comorbidities in the UK population or
something like that but the phrase
plant-based is right there and if you're
curious that that paper showed that yes
people who eat more plant-based aluminum
consumption are healthier 22 less likely
to die due to any cause during the 15
years of follow-up so it's really
getting out there and there's and you
know you mentioned the the pandemic and
for me
the the pandemic totally changed how I
talk about food and food production and
health
when I speak to patients and when I
speak at conferences when I talk when
I'm given the opportunity like this I
have a microphone in front of me so for
for years is it I mean health and gut
health and public health epidemiology
and data brought me to recommending a
healthy Whole Food plant-based diet
so for years I would avoid talking about
animal agriculture
because I was worried well first of all
it's not my very expertise and I was
also a little bit worried that people
would hear me talking about this and say
oh yeah he said all that stuff about gut
health and disease but actually he's he
only cares about animals you know so
he's he's biased or whatever but when we
went in to the pandemic it became very
clear very early on that number one the
diseases that are driven by the uh you
know the animal heavy uh Ultra processed
food heavy standard Western dialect type
2 diabetes heart disease hypertension
various cancers or suddenly even more
dangerous because we already knew they
were taking years off our life but now
they were also major risk factors for
hospitalization and death we saw that
data coming out of out of China
initially then we saw it in New York
City when New York City was at the
epicenter of the epicenter at my own
experience during the code first wave as
a Frontline clinician treating patients
who were dying from covid very much
reflected that so patients who already
had these so-called pre-existing
conditions which were driven in large
part by our standard Western diet so
there was that and then in July
of 2020 so we're maybe seven months into
the pandemic the UN issued a report
um talking about how to prevent the next
pandemic so how do we stop this from
happening again and the number one thing
that they said we could each do as an
individual or as a nation or as a
government is to step back from animal
agriculture to step away from me so it's
the same answer right so why is that
it's because the you know the dietary
pattern that requires the 82 kilograms
of meats for every adult in the UK 100
kilograms of meat every year for every
adult in the United States 100 kilograms
absolutely necessitates that we keep 80
billion animals in conditions in cramped
unsanitary unnatural conditions for
their short lives before we turn them
into food so their diseases have never
been more able to multi multiply and
develop and modify and have never had
greater opportunity to jump into humans
zoonotic diseases it's a very old lesson
it's as old as animal agriculture 10
years ago I mean I I was on the front
line during this pandemic during the
swine flu pandemic 10 years ago I was
there as a younger doctor helping to
treat people on the itu with swine flu
killed 500 million people in the first
year mostly under the age of 65 came out
of a pig farm
more billovirus bovine more billovirus
became measles when we domesticated the
cow jumped into humans killed unknown
millions of people mostly children let a
lot of children terribly disabled
throughout their lives thank God we have
measles vaccination now but we still
have probably got 200 000 people a year
dying from measles so the mostly
children so this whole zoonotic pandemic
thing is a very very old lesson and the
thing we can do is step away from me so
rich you often say
and I've obviously I'm an avid listener
do you often say and you guys have heard
Rich say this that you know we don't
change until we hurt
we don't change until there's pain and
we don't change until we identify how
our daily habit is driving pain so
here's a question for everybody we've
seven million people are dead seven
million people have died so far in the
covet pandemic 700 million people were
affected by covid and many of them are
living with long covet and all of those
debilitating symptoms which quite quite
honestly we don't yet have an answer for
in the medical community we had to shut
our businesses we had to lock up our
elderly and Elderly Care Facilities
the elderly relatives who survived the
first wave were then condemned to you
know six to 12 months of solitary
confinement unable to see their loved
ones we had to teach our kids to
socially distance from everybody not to
hug their friends not to see their
teacher
so the question that occurs to me now as
we're crawling away out of this is have
we suffered enough
have we experienced enough pain to
recognize that our daily habit and the
way we're treating food and treating
animals
brought all of this on us and it's not
new happened 10 years ago as well and
the change needs to happen I hope that
people have learned something from this
um during the first two years the
pandemic Global meat consumption went
down for the first time in decades and I
thought well that's good news that's
fantastic news because maybe the
standard Western doubt peaked out in
2019 and peaked out in 2020 and
hopefully meat production is going to
get lower and lower and lower and lower
and although I mean although the you
know the alternative Mis products uh may
not be ideal for your gut health I mean
I'm all about the whole plants I know
for a lot of people they don't want to
eat them but you know and they're not
for me but for meat eaters maybe that's
a way out I mean I think it's ambitious
to think that everyone on Earth is going
to stop beating Meese but everyone on
Earth should stop eating animal meat
great thank you
well thank you gentlemen this is really
informative and we're all convinced
about plant-based and high quality
protein that comes out of out of Plant
Nutrition just kind of in a practical
way real simple question
um
food combinations
and having a healthy gut biome a couple
of food combinations you might suggest
that people seek out
or maybe a couple of combinations to
maybe avoid so that we have a little
more comfortable tummy
so the idea of food combination so
combining Foods
I don't think there's good signs to say
oh I should have my beans with my rice
and that sort of thing so as long as
you're establishing that healthy dietary
pattern that can be really helpful if
you're suffering from bloating you just
said make my tummy more comfortable so
if you're referring to kind of bloating
and excess gas and discomfort then the
first thing to understand is that you
know I said this earlier burping and
farting and pooing that's normal that's
human okay so it's normal to get a bit
of gas it's normal to fart it's normal
to burp that's a healthy human gut right
there but if it's getting to the point
where it's uncomfortable and causing
distension you lean back into all of
those things we talked about good sleep
Stress Management make sure you're
building your Healthy diverse
plant-based plate plate unprocessed
plant derived Foods Etc and you work on
that for a few weeks and then if you're
still having problems and by the way at
this point you should have talked to
your doctor that we haven't said that
yet if you're struggling with digestive
health problems please go and talk to
your doctor even if they know nothing
about food they're really good at
detecting red flag symptoms and
organizing the important tests and scans
or poop tests that are needed to make
sure nothing serious is going on but if
you have done all that you've been to
your doctor and you've had the basic
tests and everything you're given the
okay then where do you go I guess that's
the question well often for individuals
who are eating a plant-based diet well
not often I think it often comes to me
because I see the people having problems
right I mean a plant-based diet supports
good gut health but when you are running
into trouble with bloating and
distension there's a few things that can
help so mindful eating so coming at your
meal time with a bit of presence we all
have busy lives we're kind of sitting at
the computer on a zoom meeting kind of
sneaking a sandwich in the side of our
mouth now we were speaking yesterday
about how we eat with our eyes you know
we're talking about beautiful food here
with some of the attendees but that is
so true because digestion begins in the
brain so even before you eat food your
digestive system is kicking in so if you
close your eyes right now and think of
that delicious meal that you had last
night you're going to start salivating
your tummy is going to give a little
gurgle what is that that is your
digestive system preparing for food and
if you were eating unconsciously you're
just you know sneaking that sandwich in
the side of your mouth or slabbing that
protein shake in between workouts and
that's your lunch you're not setting
your gut up for Success you're not
initiating the peristaltic waves you're
not producing the enzymes to effectively
digest that food that's number one I'm
going to give you another tip right now
that you know those uh click betty
things do this one thing to improve your
gut health
do this one thing to improve your gut
health
clip that
put a footstool in front of your toilet
okay so so you squatty potty so humans
are Apes
we are designed to poop in a squatting
position the the muscles and the anatomy
to
affect a comfortable and effective bowel
movement it's incredibly complex I'm
lucky enough to get to see that on on
scans right so you so you can see it on
a scan and when you do a colonoscopy
that's one of the nice things within
gastroenter is you get to look up close
at the living organ that you're trying
to fix with endoscopy okay okay bit icky
for some people but I gotta tell you
just absolutely fascinating but so
humans are designed to poop like an ape
to poop in a squatting position the
modern flush toilet that we have in the
western world has got a lot more to do
with Victorian sensibility than human
anatomy it looks a bit like a throne
bit of a chair in fact Queen Elizabeth
the first was one of the first people to
have as a uh flush toilet in her house
her nephew John Harrington invented it
for Britain you know it was elsewhere as
well the Chinese had it for years before
decades Millennia before but the modern
flush toilet as we know it sits you sit
up straight
like you're on an armchair or a high
chair and you try and poo You're not set
up for it so if you don't have the
ability to have a Squatty Potty or squat
in the woods
get your knees up so put a footstool it
needs to be so that your knees are
higher than your waistline and you can
lean forward and hug it in a little bit
and you're now in a squat position and
it will just slide right house
[Applause]
my question is for people that are sold
and are deciding okay I want to change
this I'm jumping in I'm going
plant-based about how long can you
expect effects to start taking place so
we touched a little bit on the gut
microbiome earlier and I can refer you
back to to Rich's seven or eight other
pods to go even deeper on that but so
how quickly does the food that we begin
to change or go microbiome so the food
that so the human digestive system is
incredible it is magical
um we've got the surface area but size
of half a tennis court in our small
intestine and basically if you feed it
almost anything within reason it will
get to work and it will extract the
proteins and the carbohydrates and the
lipids and the nutrients the Magnesium
the calcium and the iron and all that
stuff you need to build a healthy body
and repair a healthy body and what's
left over what doesn't get digested by
the small intestine is the residue we
call it a chyme or chime in in medicine
right so that gets delivered to your
large bowel to your colon and now that
becomes food for your gut microbiome so
the gut microbes go to work on it and
start to digest it and not only do they
digest it they turn it into other stuff
postbiotics and some of those
post-biotics now become food for other
bugs so it gets really complex really
quick but in essence your the food that
you eat affects your gut microbiome in a
very real way and if you choose today to
have a standard Western meal
um so let's say uh steak and white
potato with butter and gravy something
like that okay or a Big Mac
so your body is amazing it will get all
the nutrients it can out of that meal to
support the healthy body what's left
over contains some residual animal
protein contains a lot of bile because
when you eat those high fat foods you
have to make a lot of bile to emulsify
the fat and digester and there's hardly
any fiber in there there aren't any
polyphenols and but you've got microbes
can work with that okay they'll figure
it out but the microbes that thrive on
that sort of food produce predominantly
unhelpful
post-biotic substances so things like
secondary bile acids which are
carcinogenic
trimethylamine which you know enters
your bloodstream becomes trimethylamine
oxide or and a nitrogen oxide which
helps to promote coronavascular disease
um not so much the short chain fatty
acids which are really healthy so that's
a gut microbiome environment that is
conducive to chronic inflammation and
disease it'll help to get you there okay
but then you next day you say okay I'm
going to change all that but anything
like that for years so now I'm going to
you know I'm gonna have the lentil
burger and instead of the you know the
white potato mashed up a butter and salt
and cream I'm just gonna do some sweet
potato and I'm gonna have that instead
and I'm going to have some greens okay
so now you're eating a completely
different way you've got my your small
intestine your digestive tract your
stomach do their thing
all the nutrients the fats the
carbohydrates the protein the healthy
plant-based protein the Magnesium the
folate the vitaminated all that good
stuff all gets absorbed right so now
you've got a different residue for your
gut microbiome from that one meal
you are feeding a different subset
there's a certain subset of bacteria
they're now going to thrive on that
residue and that residue there's hardly
any bile in there because it's not a
high fat meal there's no animal protein
in there because you don't need animal
protein there's fiber there's a
diversity of fiber there's microbiome
available carbohydrates it's polyphenols
and now you're feeding a different
subset there's a subset of bacteria that
you never feeding differently and what
do they produce they don't produce the
secondary bile acids they don't produce
the harmful hydrogen sulphide gas they
produce vitamins
they produce short chain fatty acids
which are so many benefits for health
Way Beyond gut health but in essence
you're now building a gut micro
microbial environment that is promotes
healthy cell metabolism DNA repair
anti-carcinogenesis you're building a
healthy gut microbiome that is not
conducive to disease
those changes start after the first meal
okay and we know from a study that was
done in 2014 that if you take people and
put them on that healthy diet you can
measure the changes in their gut
microbiome function within four days a
few years ago there was a study done a
fascinating study where they went to
they got volunteers from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania African Americans who very
unfortunately have a high risk of colon
cancer about 1 in 15 would be that the
lifetime risk and they then went to
rural Africa and recruited an
age-matched population of people living
in rural Africa so these were people who
were living and eating very differently
to each other so everybody got a
colonoscopy what a great study to sign
up for so everybody got a colonoscopy
and what they found was that in the
people living Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
half of them already had pre-cancerous
bowel polyps fifty percent had
pre-cancerous battle polyps in the
people living in rural Africa they
didn't find one single precancer Spell
polyp which makes makes sense because
colorectal cancer is very very very rare
in that locality it's almost unheard of
they also analyze their gut microbiome
and they found that the Americans were
fully stacked in terms of their bowel
cancer risk so an unhealthy gut
microbiome low production short chain
fatty acids high production secondary
bile acids and they also measured the
proliferation race in the lining of the
bowel and it was high in the Americans
showing that the gut was having to
repair repair repair repair which is a
sign which is an indicator of cancer
risk and of course the Africans
completely opposite profile
so what they did next with that study
was fascinating because they just
detailed everybody's diet
and then they did a food swap
so the Americans were now getting I
think about 50 grams of fiber a day
they're eating African potato salad kale
they were you know it wasn't entirely
plant-based but it was pretty close
and what they did they did that for two
weeks and the Africans had uh you know
steak and mashed potatoes and hot dogs
and beans and all that kind of stuff and
after just two weeks they did another
colonoscopy again a great study to sign
up before you got to get two
colonoscopies in two weeks and what they
showed and they did a gut microbiome
analysis as well and what they showed
out in just two weeks those profiles had
completely flipped
so they had completely flipped so now
the Africans had a had a high risk
profile okay just what during the study
but the Americans had a low risk profile
across the board and the mucosal
proliferation race went down so within
two weeks 14 days you can establish that
change so just think Becky what you
could do in 14
weeks 14 months 14 years
yeah beautiful we have time for one more
question there's a lot of people who
want to ask questions you guys you guys
want to Duke it out
okay so Alan my family is plant-based
and I want my friends and family to try
a more plant-based diet because I see
the benefits in my family and the health
benefits and I just want them to be
healthier
and a challenge that I've come across is
sometimes sometimes people will say well
I tried it and I didn't feel good or I
tried it and I was tired all the time or
and so I don't really that's a tough one
because I don't want to sound uncaring
like well you're doing it wrong just do
it better or or seem like oh I don't
care if you you know it's still better
for you even if you're tired how do you
answer that
yeah that's a good question and it kind
of feeds into this kind of recent
concept we've had that there's the
concept of Precision Nutrition where
everybody should eat differently and in
the Precision Nutrition piece is very
interesting the science is fascinating
the studies that are being published are
really really fascinating
um but is it better than what you said
you know just you just eat a plant-based
diet you know so the one of the world's
leading or one most prestigious
um Precision Nutrition companies just a
few months or I think it was last year
okay preventomics big european-wide uh
company seven incredible academic
institutions EU funded
um looked at that okay so is there a
certain way for people to eat and what
they do is they take your blood and they
take your saliva they do genetic testing
they figure out how you handle sugar how
you handle protein they measure your
metabolism they measure your gut
microbial metabolites in your
bloodstream and they come back with your
individual plan for you they've got an
app called the M system it gives you
meal ideas and you're told to cook like
this so you might be a bit lower lower
carb a bit higher protein you know if
that's the Precision Nutrition thing
which is kind of the ultimate a version
of what you just described is it right
for me so in this trial that was
published last year they got 100 people
who needed to lose a bit of weight and
improve their insulin sensitivity Etc
and they put 50 of them through this
incredibly advanced multi-amix process
and the other 50 they subscribed to a
healthy plant-based
um meal delivery service
and there was no calorie restriction and
they told people they supplied 60 so
sent to their food and said when you're
not doing the free food I want you to
cook like the free food so kind of a
real world sort of thing and what
happened with that study is that
everybody did pretty well but the
multi-armic individual nutrition people
didn't do any better than the people who
were just told eat more healthy
plant-based meals fruits vegetables
whole grains legumes nuts and seeds so
the the kind of outcome from that study
is that the kind of Precision Nutrition
Advocates still have some work to do to
tell us that what they're recommending
is better than just getting people to
eat the foods that have been supporting
a healthy gut and healthy human body for
Millennia okay so there's that sort of
aspects I think some people think oh I
should do that program to find out what
I should eat right but I think if you're
embar if you are embarking on a
plant-based diet for the first time
there's a few things that can really
help with the success of that the first
thing to say is the Paradigm that we've
just described 50 fruits and vegetables
like one-third whole grains plenty of
legumes Etc that's incredibly versatile
that can accommodate any food culture
any preference whether you like soft
food or crunchy food
Umami food or sweeter food it can
accommodate so one thing you can do is
okay I like I like lamb casserole so
instead of switching to a kale smoothie
for my dinner instead of having a lamb
casserole I'm going to Google for a
healthy vegan casserole which is using
you know probably black beans or lentils
if I like having chicken tacos I'm gonna
do maybe chickpea tacos and I'm gonna
just so you're not turning everything on
its head you're still developing recipes
that are like what you're used to eating
and then you will find by rotating
through these recipes oh I like that I
can cook that my family like that the
kids like that I mean you go to the same
Journey whatever what kind of food you
eat right you're looking for meals at
your kids and you can both enjoy so with
that by involving the kids and I'm just
speaking my kids to have three kids but
involving the kids in the process you
will find foods that serve you serve
them that you all enjoy it's number one
number two get support so sometimes you
can feel like you're on a lonely Furrow
going plant-based and not everyone
around you is on the same Journey as you
in terms of learning education
motivation support commitment so find a
body you know in your neighborhood a
friend a cousin someone you say hey I'm
doing this plant-based challenge for 30
days can you join me because then it
becomes fun and now you're sharing
recipes and you're bringing potlucks
over to each other's homes and it
becomes a joyous thing it shouldn't be
about deprivation and of course the
other thing is that a healthy Whole Food
plant-based diet is a great way to eat
so if you enjoy food because the meals
are naturally lower in calories so you
get to eat more food so don't forget to
eat more food don't be hungry you don't
you you need bigger plates maybe you
need two plates while you're doing this
and while you're filling up those big
plates I think a lot of people embarked
on a healthy plant-based diet and
they've still got that carb phobia
ingrained so deeply and I agree that
sweets and pastries and croissants and
purified sugars are not good for us they
should make up less than 500 for
calories but the healthy whole carbs the
sweet potatoes the you know the tomatoes
the beans all of those healthy carbs
actually serve us really really well
they're very sadiating they're very good
for us we know that you know plant-based
populations that do really well actually
eat a lot of healthy whole carbs so
don't so get the carb phobia out of
there so no carb phobia
eat more food eat familiar food and
involve some friends and make it fun
awesome
yeah cool thank you and for people that
aren't here who are listening if they
want to connect with you beyond the book
um where would you like to direct those
people
I've only got time for one social media
platform except for you I'm super busy
so Instagram if you just look for Dr
Alan Desmond on Instagram you'll find me
there and you know through the links you
can learn more about the book about the
incredible online course I remembered
our mutuals Stephen and David Flynn and
some of the live events that I run in
the UK because if you're hearing this
I'd love to see you at one of those Live
Events so so watch out for announcements
we've got Andy ramage coming up next we
can't have an episode of ritual without
a shout out to Andy it's because Andy
who we just had dinner with in Florence
the other day told me the whole origin
story behind his involvement and your
kind of trajectory in the in the the
plant-based medical world which is
fascinating so it all ties together so
it is all one right yeah yeah did you
want to hear this do you want to hear
that story sure why not so Andy uh
co-founder of one year no beer so I was
at a medical conference back in 2017 and
I'd had one of these experiences that I
often have at medical conferences where
I was at an industry Spa sponsored
Symposium and again the medications are
great I prescribe them all the time but
we need every evidence-based tool in the
Box to get healthy so I'm at an industry
sponsored medical Symposium and a very
prominent gastroenterologist gives a
keynote on the eight studies that we
need in GI health and he didn't mention
food once or diet and lifestyle once so
I stood up and got the mic and said hey
shouldn't we be that's amazing but
shouldn't we be doing more studies and
putting more funding into giving answers
to that question that every single
patient asks every single one of us what
about food you know shouldn't we be
doing that and if there was like a red
button under the podium he was probably
pressing it because you know I felt like
I just left off a stink bomb okay so
anyway afterwards a few people came up
to and said hey good on you you know and
then we talked I connected some
like-minded gastroenterologists which
was lovely but I had a phone call with
Andy later that afternoon and we were
talking about plant-based Andy's
plant-based and he said hey you know and
I told that whole story he said you
should speak to Tom Hubbard I met this
doctor called Tom Hubbard on the ritual
retreat in Ireland and he's a
plant-based doctor and I said okay cool
I'll talk to Tom wonderful so I spoke to
Tom fantastic lovely chap great guy and
with a lot in common and then he said
have you met Dr Shireen Kazam
in London so she's an oncologist and she
is trying to set up the first medical
conference in the UK on the benefits of
a healthy Whole Food plant-based diet
you should speak to her because maybe
you could speak at the conference and I
thought wow I can get to speak at a
conference this is amazing I mean I'd
often been inspired by doctors and
dietitians like Garth Davis and Neil
Bernard and Michael Greger Juliana
Heather Michelle mcmack and Brenda Davis
all these people I discovered through
the ritual podcast and I thought now I
can we're going to do this in the UK
amazing so I phoned um Shireen and
introduced myself and Trina said oh yeah
we're doing a conference it's going to
be Kings and in London it's going to be
great it'll be great if you would speak
and I thought oh thank you so much for
the opportunity I'll be there
what I found out years later was from
Shireen was that when she was organizing
the conference I was the first person to
say yes
so I came off that call and was yes I
get to speak at a plant-based conference
and Shireen came off that call went yes
we're going to have a conference and you
know and it was so awesome and at that
conference it brought together a whole
community of doctors including shrink
Kazam and Gemma Newman and myself with
Andy Davis who visited from Australia
for that conference and that was the
formation of plant-based health
professionals UK there was about eight
of us there initially we now have over a
thousand members so shout out to
plant-based out professionals UK and it
used to be I knew everybody's name now I
know hardly anybody's name in the
organization and I'm still an ambassador
for that group and Shireen is doing
incredible things with that group but we
can draw a line from there back to Andy
back to the retreat the previous Retreat
you had in Ireland yeah beautiful thank
you I love that yeah what a way to end
it thank you it all comes back to plan
power Italia the origin of it all right
yeah sure something now so just to
mention
um it's so profound like so amazing so
Tom Hubbard
um we had gone to plant power Ireland we
just did one retreated plant power
Ireland and it was really a blast like
really an extraordinary place but uh Tom
Hubbard actually
um uh his wife at the time uh Carmella
had reached out to me and told me that
he was very very ill and we had an open
spot at the retreat so we had met them
previously
um I was in Ireland for my friend's
wedding I have an Irish girlfriend who
has four beautiful children and her
husband promised her an Irish wedding so
they had it 12 years after they were
together with all the kids and she
invited me to sing in her wedding and
all of the kid all of my kids and me we
went to Ireland so we're in Ireland and
I'm posting on Instagram Rich was not
able to join us and I get this message
on IG came from this woman Carmel and
she's like why don't you come over and
I'll make you a plant-based breakfast
so I kind of said well she sent me some
these coordinates and I said okay you
know we're on our way back to Dublin but
if it works and it's easy then we'll
figure it out and so we had these
coordinates so we drove and we she said
you know my husband Tom will meet you at
these coordinates so we arrived to this
location and there's this guy on a
motorcycle and he says come with me and
we drive through these gigantic tall
like grasses like you can't see you know
it's like a tunnel and we're drawing and
he's driving and he stops and we pull in
and we arrive and it's two sisters
um with their husbands and one of the
husbands is an artist from Brooklyn and
they've prepared this amazing
plant-based meal and we're all there and
we have this amazing time and then they
say wait you can't leave until we take
you to the magical forest
so we say okay so so we drive and drive
and on the hill in the Horizon you see
this Knoll of just it's like all
farmland and then this just independent
Forest
and I had my sitar with me and I
remember we pulled out and we walked
into a magical fairy kingdom that is not
to be described it was like trees tree
beans with moss all over them I mean it
was it was out of a movie it was
absolutely magical and I was like I have
to play my sitar and grab the sitar and
we were all sort of like hanging on the
trees and it was just a magical Moment
Like mind-blowing Beyond and then they
also shared with us that there were
tunnels underneath this tree uh
ecosystem that we're reaching to these
sacred places I mean it was crazy so
then okay cut two years later we do the
plant power Island Retreat and Carmel
um contacts me and she's like Tom's ill
like he almost died like he's a doctor
and his levels were through the floor
and he couldn't figure out what's going
on so I said we have an open space bring
him
so he comes to the retreat and uh and
he's so happy to see us and he's eating
our plant-based menu and the place is
magical and we have this ritual Circle
and Tom's also a drummer and so he
brought his drum and he starts drumming
and he ends up like on the table
sweating like his whole body was just
moving everywhere he was like a work of
art in every level and he was so alive
and clearly uh just feeling amazing so I
sat down to next to him at dinner
and he tells me that it was the first
time that he felt good in like maybe a
year and that he really thought that he
might be leaving his body and I and this
guy was just like he was dancing on the
table is it crazy then he tells me you
know Julie he said that time that you
met me you know at the coordinates to
come over to our house for the
plant-based breakfast he said you know I
grew up in these corn fields and I've
been I've grown up there my whole life
and he said you were late like you
weren't there and I was waiting and
waiting you weren't there and he goes
and I wanted to go down to the creek and
he said so I started to walk down to
this Creek or streamer River and he said
a black crow came and flew over my head
and hit me with its wings and he said
and then I I kind of walked back to the
space and then you weren't there and he
said and I did it again and he said the
crow came six times to bat me on my head
to make sure that I waited for you
and uh and he said I just had to share
that with you I mean this is the magical
mystical undercurrent of how we're being
drawn together
um and so it's lovely to hear that
that's how you're here yes so that's it
beautiful fantastic uh what a delight
um I don't know about you guys but I got
a tremendous amount of value out of that
experience uh Alan's book is called the
plant-based diet Revolution he brought a
copy here maybe you leave it out and
people can peruse it over the course of
that I sure will I sure will pick it up
in the meantime and uh I'm sure plenty
of people here are going to be tugging
on your shirt tails to ask their
questions that didn't get asked today so
you've been very gracious with your time
I appreciate it it is a blessing and an
honor to have you with us this week and
you have an open invitation to visit the
studio sometime and we'll do round two
okay I look forward to it round one was
awesome so let's do it yeah cool thank
you Dr Alan Desmond everybody thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]